oh my gosh do you know what this is it's
an Xbox baby grogu Mandalorian themed
controller I mean this is honestly like
the cutest thing that I've ever seen
oh look at
it at her he's even got his little
blankets ah
smells like my mind like this is so cute
like I want to keep this as a display so
here's the little blanket and the
controller it has a little tiny sweater
I mean this is freaking adorable
like have you seen anything more cute I
don't think you have so here's the
controller
it's got the Mandalorian logo on the
back it's a pretty basic controller like
there's really nothing too super special
about it I mean it does have like the
pale green color to match grogu I do
like the white buttons up here on the
top and I mean it's pretty simple but
this little sweater is really what makes
it special look at that it's unreal it's
just the cutest thing ever
explain